[موسيقى]
يا الله اني اتهم جمله قصيره يستلها
السوريون الان من روايات الظلم في التاريخ
الانساني ليكتبوها ومعها عبارات اخرى
ترادفها معنى على صفحات ماساتهم او
ليرددوها باصواتهم المخنوقه تحتوى فوق
ركام بيوتهم التي دمرها الزلزال وقد قطع
كثيرون منهم الشك اخيرا في تخاذل المجتمع
الدولي عن واجب انقاذهم بيقين تواطئه ضدهم
للروايه هنا صيغتان اولاهما تفترض فصل
الانساني عن السياسي لتدعو الى مساعده
المنكوبين باعتبارهم ضحايا كارثه طبيعيه
وفي معزل عن كل ما سبقها من صراعات بين
نظام الحكم والثائرين عليه بينما تتحدث
الثانيه عن سياق من الكوارث السياسيه التي
القت بملايين السوريين بين انياب الزلزال
الجيولوجي وليس من الحكمه تجاهلها عند
الحديث عن وجهه عمليات الاغاثه
كان لابد والحال هذه من الم الانتظار
بكلفته البشريه الباهظه حتى يكتمل سيناريو
الاحداث على ارض الواقع ويصل الى نتيجته
الفاجعه التي قد لا تختلف عليها الروايات
في اليوم الاول وقع الزلزال المدمر وتحدثت
الانباء عن ضحايا باعداد من خانتين او
ثلاث في اليوم الثاني صارت الخانات اربعه
وفي الثالث هبت عشرات الدول لارسال فرق
الاغاثه الى تركيا ثم في الرابع بدا
المنكوبون في شمال غرب سوريا يدركون ان
مناطقهم مستثناه من رافت العالم التزاما
بقرارات سابقه كانت توافقت عليها الدول
الكبرى في الامم المتحده حول طرق ارسال
المعونات اليهم ومع حلول اليوم الخامس
تعالت التساؤلات عن عدد الايام التي
يستطيع الانسان فيها ان يبقى على قيد
الحياه من دون ماء او غذاء
عند هذا الجزء المروع من السيناريو سيطل
فاصل سياسي قصير وقد يقال ان قليلا من
السياسه لن يزيد كميه الركام على اجساد
الناس المطمرين تحت انقاذ بيوتهم في شمال
غرب سوريا ولن يقلل كميه الاكسجين التي
نضبت لديهم او تكاد غير انه قد ينفع في
مساعده الباقين على قيد الحياه هناك ومن
يتعاطفون معهم على رؤيه ما يتوارى من
اجزاء الصوره وراء الركام وهي اجزاء ستظهر
فيها الولايات المتحده الامريكيه التي غزت
العراق واحتلت برغم انف الدول الكبرى
والصغرى في الامم المتحده قد صارت تتحجج
منذ سنين بالفيديو الروسي في مجلس الامن
الدولي لتمتنع ومعها بقيه الدول الغربيه
عن ادخال كيس من الاغذيه والادويه الى
شمال غرب سوريا الا بموافقه الكرملين اما
العرب او اكثريه انظمه حكمهم فما عاد
لديهم هم فيما يتعلق بالشان السوري سوى
تعويم الرئيس بشار الاسد حتى ولو على دم
ضحايا الزلزال في حين اصبحت الدول
الاقليميه الكبرى تتلاقى ايضا على الموقف
نفسه او لا تعترض عليه وان كان لكل منها
سببه مختلف تركيا تنكفئ على معالجات
نصيبها من الزلزال عشيه انتخاباتها
المرتقبه في ايار مايو المقبل وايران
تواصل التمسك بموقفها في نصره نظام الحكم
واسرائيل التي حظيت بجبهه هادئه في
الجولان طوال خمسه عقود من حكم ال الاسد
والمحكومه اليوم بيمين دينيا متطرف تعتبر
بلسان حاخاماتها ان ما حدث عقاب الهي
للمسلمين بعربهم واتراكهم على حد سواء
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]